Jessica Dy okay Chris Bard and it's a
website is
Crea
[Music]
it and why should we see your
series I should do it's a great it's a
great project k d produced it as well
but she directed it coot it with Sasha
SE um just a great collaboration with
Mike E with the sound um and it it gives
you a little taste as far as what you're
supposed to believe and what you're not
supposed to believe as far as in
perspective and how did you secure
fundance for your project independently
yeah independently um meaning how did
you pay for it I just I you know I
raised funds uh last year for three
independent films so when we were
speaking about it that's kind of what I
brought to the table was the funding
aspect um wealthy individuals Angel
anding hostage no and and how are you
guys promoting the film are we promoting
it yeah um you know it's just very
select we're not doing a lot of
promotion with it was just a
collaboration to to accomplish a goal
and work on uh projects you know further
down the road as far as
[Music]
features